[Music]
thank you
in his piece on fairies stories Jr
Tolkien is going to set out three
guiding questions and when it comes to
the question of Origins he's going to
say that I'm going to pass lightly over
this question I'm too unlearned to deal
with it in any other way but and here's
the key it is the least important of the
three questions from my purpose and a
few remarks will suffice so what are
these three questions well one of them
is what is the origin of fairy tales
historically in terms of how they emerge
and develop into what they are but the
first question which he thinks is more
important is well what are fairy stories
so the question of what we could call
Essence is more important than the
question of Origins and then the third
question is what is the you truths that
are made out of fairies stories and
again Tolkien thinks that that is a more
important more revealing question for us
than this one of Origins but he's not
going to pass over it in just a
paragraph he's going to say quite a few
things and much of what he's telling us
is you could say by way of
setting something out and then negating
it and then drawing some conclusion from
that so the first thing is he thinks
that there's a mistaken approach that
develops in looking at the question of
Origins and he's not saying that it's
completely flawed he's saying well
there's a certain truth to it there's a
certain value he actually talks about a
perfectly legitimate procedure in itself
and what is that perfectly legitimate
procedure in itself you know looking at
the basic components or the elements of
fairy tales and then trying to associate
them figure out you know which led to
which on that basis you could call this
in some respects this could be a little
bit misleading a structural approach
that looks at the fairy tale as
essentially a structure of particular
elements and he gives some examples of
this
he tells us there's a lot of elements in
fairy tales such as this detachable
heart or Swan robes magic rings
arbitrary prohibitions Wicked
stepmothers and even fairies themselves
and these can be studied without
tackling the question of origin and he
says that these studies are however
scientific at least in intent they're
the pursuit of folklorus or
anthropologists people using the stories
not as they were meant to be used but as
a quarry from which to dig evidence or
information about matters in which they
are interested and he says yeah this is
legitimate you know different Sciences
or disciplines can do their own thing
with this but the question is what
really is going to count and he says
that to investigators of this sort
recurring similarities seems specially
important so students of folklore have
to get off on their own proper track or
Express themselves in a misleading
shorthand misleading in particular if it
gets out of their monographs into books
about literature so when it moves from
their scholarly work into literary
criticism then we've got a problem here
and what's the the problem they are
inclined to say any two stories that are
built round the same folklore motive or
are made up of a generally similar
combination of such motives are in
quotes the same stories we read that
Beowulf is only a version of dot uh and
mannequin that the Black Bull of Norway
is Beauty and the Beast are the same
story as Eros and psyche that the Norse
Master made or the Gaelic Battle of the
birds and its many congeners and
variants is the same story as the Greek
tale of Jason and Madea and you know we
do see a lot of this with people who
want to approach stories you could say
from the top down and also from the
bottom up just looking at elements and
they miss the middle part don't they
so what does Tolkien have to say
he says that
the problem is that they leave out the
coloring the atmosphere the
unclassifiable individual details of a
story and above all
the general purport that informs with
life the undissected bones of the plot
that really count
Shakespeare's King Lear is not the same
as Lehman's story in his brute or to
take the extreme case of Red Riding Hood
it is of merely secondary interest that
the retold versions of this story in
which the little girl is saved by
woodcutters is directly derived from
Perot's story in which he was eaten by
the wolf the really important thing is
that the latter version has a happy
ending more or less and if we do not
mourn the grandmother over much and that
perrose version had not and that is a
very profound difference he says so what
they're missing out on what they're
ignoring
is all the other aspects of the story
and this is where we get people saying
silly silly things like well this story
over here is the exact same thing as
this they're all the heroes Journey For
example you know is is a great example
from our own time no they're not all the
heroes journey and they're not all the
heroes Journey even if they are in the
same way some of them are crap and some
of of them are great and it's not the
fact of being a hero's journey that
makes a story what it is
so the other thing that he says here in
this respect is that I don't deny the
fascination of the desire to unravel the
income intricately knotted and ramified
history of the branches on the tree of
tales it is closely connected with the
study of this the Tangled skein of
language of which I know some small
pieces you know that Tolkien was himself
a professor of languages
and he says that even with regard to
language it seems to me the essential
quality and aptitudes of a given
language in a living Monument is both
more important to seize and far more
difficult to make explicit than its
linear history by attending to the
history we lose sight of the richness of
language
so he says with regard to fairy stories
I feel it is more interesting and also
in its own way more difficult to
consider what they are what they have
become for us and I love this phrase
what values the long alchemic processes
of time have produced in them and here
he's going to give us a very pregnant
metaphor that he's going to follow up on
a little bit later in descent's words I
would say we must be satisfied with the
soup that is set before us and not
desire to see the bones of the ox out of
which it has been boiled right and so
this is where he says I'm going to pass
over the question of Origins and then he
comes to talking about certain debates
taking place between
philologists and other people who are
working on stories and he says that
there's a debate between three different
things going on
independent Evolution or invention
meaning that this particular story
identified with these elements or
markers develops on its own it is an
origin point and we could have
independent origin points in different
places the second he says
um inheritance from a common ancestry
right and he is going to call this a
little bit later
borrowing in time right then the third
is diffusion at various times from one
or more centers and he says that this is
borrowing in space very interesting ways
of talking about it and he says that
most of these debates depend on an
attempt at oversimplification the
history of fairy stories is probably
more complex than the physical history
of the human race all three things
independent invention inheritance and
diffusion have evidently played their
part in producing the intricate web of
story it's now Beyond skill all skill
but that of the elves to unravel it and
then he tells us too that invention
is doubtless the most important one that
uh all he says it's also fundamental and
not surprisingly the most mysterious
to an inventor that is to a story maker
the other two must in the end lead back
and this makes perfect sense right
inheritance you inherit from somebody
else who has produced right so
inheritance he says in this way we
arrive at last only at an ancestral
inventor
um
and then you know with with the other
diffusion only refers the problem of
origin elsewhere at the center of the
supposed diffusion there's a place where
once an inventor lived and now notice
two things here is Tolkien saying that
the only thing that counts is the origin
point of the story no he's not even
saying that he's saying these are in a
certain sense leading us off the track
because we don't just want to know where
did a story ultimately come from we want
to know with the products of inheritance
and diffusion how did the story change
how did it develop how did it evolve how
did it get better richer more
interesting better told right so the
mere fact of being able to trace
something back to a supposed origin
point which a lot of times it's fairly
uh speculative
it's not really answering the problem
so
we can shift our perspective and this is
part of what he's trying to get us to do
in this section and three main ways he
starts up by talking about how Max
Mueller's view of Mythology is a disease
of language we should abandon that and
he says mythology is not a disease at
all
though it may like human beings become
diseased you may as well say that
thinking is a disease of the mind it
would be more near the truth to say that
languages are a disease of Mythology but
language cannot be dismissed the
Incarnate mind the tongue and the tail
are in our world co-evil
the human mind endowed with the powers
of generalization and abstraction season
not only green grass discriminating it
and finding it fair to look upon but
sees it that it is green as being grass
so we need to be actually attentive to
language we need to not dismiss it we
need to realize how important and
mysterious it is for us and then we also
need to have an attentiveness
to what he's going to call fairy
he says how powerful how stimulating to
the very faculty that produced it was
the invention of the adjective no spell
or incantation in fairy is more potent
and that is not surprising such
incantations might be said to be only
another view of adjectives a part of
speech in a mythical grammar and he goes
on and he talks about
um in fantasy as it is called new form
is made fairy begins man becomes a sub
Creator these are three key Concepts
that he's tying together in just one
little phrase let me repeat that
in such fantasy as it is called new form
is made fairy begins man becomes a sub
Creator and here is this line an
essential power of fairy is thus the
power of making immediately effective by
the will the visions of fantasy
he goes on and he he talks about this as
being a type of sub-creation this aspect
of Mythology something different than
either representation or symbolic
interpretation and he says we don't
consider this enough so what is the
connection between myth and folk tale
and fairy story
so he says you know maybe people don't
pay attention to this because fairy
tales are thought to belong to the lower
mythology rather than to the higher
there's been much debate concerning the
relations of these things folk tale and
myth and he says that we should consider
this at one time Tolkien says it was a
dominant view that all of these matters
were derived from nature myths the
Olympians were personifications of the
sun Dawn Knight and so on and all the
stories told about them were originally
myths allegories would have been a
better word of the greater Elemental
changes right so then he says epic
heroic Legends Saga and then localize
these stories in real places and
humanize them by attributing them to
ancestral Heroes mightier than men and
yet already men and finally these
Legends dwindling down became folk tales
Merchen fairy stories nurture Tales
and then he says it's actually the
opposite this is the truth almost upside
down
the nearer the so-called nature myth or
allegory of the large processes of
nature is to its supposed archetype the
less interesting it is and indeed the
less it is of a myth capable of throwing
any illumination whatsoever on to the
world and he goes on and says
personality can only be derived from a
person the gods May derive their color
and Beauty from the high splendors of
nature but it was man who obtained these
for him abstracted them from Sun and
Moon and Cloud their personality they
get direct from him and he says let's
think about an example the Norse god
Thor right his name is thunder of which
Thor is the Norse form it's not
difficult to interpret his hammer
miolinar as Lightning yet Thor has as
far as our late records go a very marked
character of personality
which cannot be found in thunder or
lightning as physical phenomena right
construing it as a mere nature myth is
not going to work
and he goes on and he says well which
came first nature allegories about
personalized Thunder in the mountains or
stories about an irascible not very
clever Red Beard farmer of strength
Beyond common measure a person very much
like Northern Farmers the the Bender by
whom Thor was cheerily beloved to a
picture of such Man Thor may be held to
have been dwindled or from the god it
may be held to have been enlarged but I
doubt whether either of you is right not
by itself not if you insist that one of
these must precede the other it is more
reasonable Tolkien says to suppose the
farmer popped up in the very moment when
Thunder got a voice and face that there
was a distant growl of thunder in the
Hills every time a Storyteller heard a
farmer in a rage and he says NOW Thor of
course is a member of the higher
aristocracy of Mythology one of the
rulers of the world
and yet the story The Tale that is told
of him uh in the Elder Edda is certainly
a fairy story
so he's saying that we can find fairy
tales right within mythology the realm
of fairy uh dealing with of course not
just nature but the supernatural as well
and he goes on and he says that these
things have become entangled or maybe
they were sundered long ago and have
since roped slowly through a Labyrinth
of error through confusion back to
refusion and what do we see here in this
shifting perspective in a sense a
refusal on tolkien's part to take the
rather speculative
assertions by the comparative
mythologists and folklorists and
philologists to tell us where the actual
origin of these things are and to say
what matters more is the kind of story
that's being told and so to that we need
to turn next